TOTAL THE SAME MONTH LAST YEAR.
BRET'S >> Bret: RICH, THANKS.
THE PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
BERNIE SANDERS SAID HEALTH CARE
IS A HUMAN RIGHT, NOT A
PRIVILEGE.
HE IS UNVEILING THE LATEST
VERSION OF HIS PLAN TO GET RID
OF PRIVATE HEALTH CARE INSURANCE
AND HAS THE GOVERNMENT FIT THE
BILL.
IT WILL COST $35 TRILLION OVER
TEN YEARS.
REPUBLICANS LOVE THE PROPOSAL AS
ELECTION SEASON WEAPON AGAINST
DEMOCRATS, SOME OF WHOM ARE NOT
THAT THRILLED ABOUT IT.
HERE IS CORRESPONDENT
PETER DOOCY >> Peter: HOW MUCH
OF A TRANS HEADER IS
BERNIE SANDERS?
HE HAS PRIMARY OPPONENTS NODDING
ALONG WITH HIM.
>> PLEASE DO NOT TELL US THAT
THIS IS A RATIONAL HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM.
>> RIGHT, RIGHT, RIGHT.
>> GILLIBRAND HERSELF TOOK THE
MICROCELL.
>> THIS HAS THE NEXT SOCIAL NEED
SAFETY NET.
NO MATTER IF YOU CAN AFFORD IT,
NO MATTER WHERE YOU LIVE, NO
MATTER WHAT.
>> Peter: SHE'S NOT THE ONLY
ONE.
ELIZABETH WARREN, KAMALA HARRIS
AND CORY BOOKER RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT WITH A NEW SPONSOR
MEDICARE FOR ALL AS PART OF
THEIR PLATFORMS.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT AND
WE ARE GOING TO DELIVER A
MEDICARE FOR ALL SINGLE-PAYER
SYSTEM.
>> Peter: BUT AMY KLOBUCHAR IS
UNCONVINCED.
>> THIS IS A STRONG IDEA OUT
THERE, BUT I THINK CLEAR WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO DO TO GET US
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE MORE
QUICKLY AND TO MOVE MORE
QUICKLY, AND THAT IS TO FIRST OF
ALL, PUT UP A PUBLIC OPTION.
>> Peter: MEDICARE FOR ALL
MEANS NOBODY PAYS PREMIUM OR
DEDUCTIBLE AND EVERYBODY PUT
UNDER THE GOVERNMENT'S CARE.
>> THIS WOULD MEAN ADDING
180 MILLION PEOPLE TO THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM.
WITH THE GOVERNMENT TAKEOVER, WE
CAN SEE FROM OTHER COUNTRIES
THAT WE WILL HAVE LONG WAIT
TIMES AND RATIONING OF
HEALTH CARE.
>> ANY QUESTIONS?
>> Peter: THIS TOTAL
TRANSFORMATION OF HEALTH CARE
WILL WIPE OUT PRIVATE INSURANCE
COMPANIES.
>> UNDER MEDICARE COME ALL BASIC
HEALTH CARE NEEDS SO THEY WILL
NOT BE THERE TO DO THAT.
I SUPPOSE IF YOU WANT TO MAKE
YOURSELF LOOK A LITTLE BIT MORE
BEAUTIFUL, YOU WANT TO WORK ON
THAT KNOWS, THEY CAN DO THAT.
>> BASICALLY BLUE CROSS BLUE
SHIELD WOULD BE REDUCED TO NOSE
JOBS.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
>> Peter: THIS PLAN REFERS TO
NOSE JOBS IN THE COMING DAYS WE
SHOULD FIND OUT WHETHER MEDICARE